[Music]
welcome to the Samuel Leeds podcast on
this week's episode I'm gonna be sat
down with a lady called khlo and she's
gonna be explaining and we're gonna be
talking about how to be a deal sorcerer
and how you can make 2,000 pounds per
day from scratch stay tuned so this is a
follow-up interview we did a documentary
together
I spent a full day with you where you
made 2,000 pound from scratch deal
sourcing friend didn't watch the video
tell us what happened you run a
competition I think it was just it was
just a Christmas time at the time when
he said people tend to you know not do
anything and things like that but
there's plenty of time because obviously
you off work and your competition was I
think it was about five different pieces
that you had to do and one of them was
to book as many properties to go of you
as possible
yeah so I did all I did that and I put
it on your Facebook page that how many
odd viewed and then I think it was a
couple of weeks later I got a message
from you I think it was saying what's
your phone number today and yeah so then
you you rang me up and I was actually on
a viewing at the time with one of my
sort of estate agents that I get I'm
really really well with and you said
that I'd won and yeah I was obviously at
you know absolutely thrilled and they'd
have to put the phone down me and I
would scream around the house it's just
hugging and everything yeah so that
that's that's what happened and then I
booked some viewings in Burnley and
obviously met you in Burnley and yeah we
viewed about eight I think in Seattle
yeah never know until you turned up no
you don't know in City turn up I did I
did learn a lesson it's no excuse
obviously but I was working you know
full-time at the time and I didn't check
everything fully I I did it on most of
them but I didn't look on street view on
one of them and obviously that was the
one with all the houses that were
boarded up so yeah
that was a big lesson for me to learn
but luckily obviously I'd book so many
it wasn't a wasted journey you know if
that was the only one because I would
never go so far and just but what
naughty you know you need you need a few
you know a few and yeah so yeah a lot
lots of different ones I think some were
sort of needed refurbishment some were
probably single at most of them were
HMOs and yeah and then we found the most
perfect one yeah and we sold that on the
day we did about 2,000 pounds yes and it
was quite surreal day because starting
from from nothing apart from some
viewings and and you or your background
I don't think I like we won in saying
this but you never saw any deals
previously you'd never made any money in
property previously I don't think not
not not deal sauce or anything like what
was your property background property
background was si okay but I didn't know
it was called si actually until I went
on the crash course first yeah it was it
was just holiday let's did you buy
something and rent it out or did you
rent something and then do as a holiday
let how did that work it was with my
ex-partner we were when we got it we
bought it together yeah and then
obviously I took over and found out
really that si made the most money then
obviously use it as a single let's yeah
but I did manage it and do everything
myself
which I'm glad I did but I would also
regret doing it because it is too much
hard work it's almost like a full-time
job I was cleaning it I was booking them
in I was key handling I was doing
everything yeah so yeah and I did that
for about ten years
Wow then yeah then unfortunately things
situations changed and obviously didn't
keep it so yeah but I had no idea it was
called the service accommodations like
don't one of those so so deal sourcing
because what I really want to get into
this is how you did what you did and I
know some of the comments as well people
were saying you know I should've never
have done that if you weren't there
there and it's like that's the point
I came with you to help you but after
that you've also gone on to do the same
and you've made some money so I want to
get on to that but I want to just give
the listeners as much information as
possible around exactly start-to-finish
a to Zed how you found some properties
package them up sold them I know to
begin with you used my investors but you
went on to find your own investors
you've made your own money how much have
you made in the last one a few weeks
three thousand pounds pause did she tell
you marry me yes so you've made five
thousand pounds yes in maybe a month or
so to about five thousand five weeks
which is phenomenal you applied for
winners Wednesday and Amelia declined
how rude she said because she wanted to
get a little bit more you know some
months into you bout to show that it's
very very consistent so for this it's
just a case of information how do you do
what you do I know you're gonna be on
witness Wednesday very very very soon as
well but let's talk deal sourcing so
firstly how do you find deals and what
kind of deals are the other type that
investors are looking for I find the
ones that they're looking for is to
refurbish ones so they can put all their
money out as much as they possibly can
right that is fine for me
I don't wander in that I think some
people find that little bit harder yes
what the calculations out there if
that's what they want and that's
absolutely fine so yeah it's it's just a
case of starting off I just literally go
into right move if I'm looking in my
area yeah I'll go onto my move look all
the properties that need some sort of
refurbishment and then obviously talk to
the estate agent yeah and then it's just
check in nearby house you know soul
price is you know what sort of thing is
going to rent for and and all the checks
that you need to do and feel the
different websites and things like that
and then obviously you go and view it
and then because sometimes on the on the
photos they're not quite showing the
cracks they're not quite showing how bad
they
actually our until you see it oh there's
just no pictures at all there's no
pictures - yeah absolutely
if they're in a bad condition sometimes
the estate agent doesn't want the facts
but they're so terrible yeah so there's
no pictures and it just says need some
motivation so okay so a lot the problems
that you've been finding them that they
are buy refurbish refinance
opportunities okay so what exactly is
that then so that's a property that
you're gonna add value to right yes and
then you're gonna be able to push the
value up so as an investor that's a I'm
an investor you're bringing a deal to me
what what's this what exactly is the
product what is the service because if
you some right move one could say oh
well I could just find it myself so what
am I paying you for the deal sorcerer as
an investor and you're paying me for the
knowledge you might not be local to that
area you might not have the time to view
it yourself and you might not have time
to do anything at all you might just be
at work all the time and just have some
money want to invest in property but
just don't have time to do it so
therefore you know then I could suggest
what area depending on what sort of you
know what you wants yeah it might be a
case of you know sort of up north again
sort of near Burnley you know - you know
if you want cheaper houses all sort of
maybe sort of Southampton if you you
know if you want the capital growth so
yeah it all depends on that I find a lot
of people you know have got the money
but they haven't absolutely no time not
even any time to really go on Rightmove
at all yeah but it's not obviously about
going to might move it's about doing you
know all the checks or you know
everything else and it's not a five
minute job it takes a long long time to
do it properly so basically then so
you've mentioned knowledge so they might
not have the know-how yes or they might
have the know-how but they don't have
the time yes so show me for instance of
course I've got I've got the know-how
but for me might be a case of I want to
invest in properties in Burnley or
wherever Middlesbrough I know it's a
good area I know the strategy I know
what to do but I haven't got the time to
view them I haven't got the time to
negotiate the price down haven't got the
time to be calling back and forth of the
agents and so I'll pay you couple
pounds and then you go sort it hand it
to me on a plate yes and then I'll go
for it which which make sense okay so
what do you actually get from paying you
what was that what's down which kind of
feeling we charged 2,000 pounds for for
the day to a buyer is that about typical
yeah sort of two to three
yeah just rebelled yeah that's the
source in um if it's deal packaging
obviously that's slightly more how much
is that then it depends sort of maybe up
to five thousand pounds but it depends
on the deal what's the difference
between deal sourcing in your packaging
dual sourcing is where you find the
property and negotiate and obviously buy
the property for for the investor deal
packaging is where if it needs say
refurbishment then you would find local
traders sort the property out maybe you
know you find out the nearest solicitor
you know and just basically do as much
as you possibly can yeah and sort of
manage the project as well okay so
that's that's why it's lightly obviously
you know you're overseeing the project
as well Oh I mean hey five thousand
sounds cheap if you're doing that and I
guess it depends on the project if it's
if they're buying a large you know
commercial to residential block it will
vary a bit but that makes sense and so
let's talk about just a standard two
three thousand pound fee okay like what
we've done on the documentary so you are
negotiating the price yes you are what
else doing the checks on the area yes
what else a view in the property itself
of course viewing it and yeah
photographs videos anything obviously
that they you know what they want what
would happen if they paid you two
thousand pounds and then the property
fell through or they got someone else
came along at the last minute and
offered more and you were good
where does that leave the investor and
where does that leave you as the deal
sorcerer um if that was the case what I
would do is I'd say to them and
fortunately this is fallen through but I
will find you a similar property for the
same sort of figures
and you know maybe the same sort of area
and therefore do it you know and then
therefore just you know replace the
property good place yes yes and what
would happen if you couldn't replace it
let's say you said to replace it but
then time is ticking weeks we're turning
into months and you hadn't replaced it
where would that leave the investor
could that leave them in a very
vulnerable position yeah of course it
could so obviously you know I would in
that situation refund them yes and is
all of this drawn up in internal yes
I've got all four terms and conditions
great so when someone buys a house off
you
you've got terms and conditions you've
got a clear agreement between if the
property falls through this happens if
you need a refund this is how it works
it's all that before they actually pay
you any money yes yes everything
yeah that's great yes okay so that makes
the investor feel much more comfortable
because they're paying you for something
but they know that they've got yeah
there's refund policies in place also
where does the legislation side of
things work I know that's something that
you've gone on and done yes
so you're now a member of the property
Ombudsman I am yes and what's your
company name it's n BPI and BPI I'm
trying to work out what that might stand
for well alright when I used to do dog
training in other businesses I'd call
myself new beginnings
oh wow so cuz I just love the name new
beginnings so I just used the NB and
then PR is property investor love new
beginnings property investor right okay
so you so since the since we met you've
set up a company yes and you become
compliant yes where did you well more
talked about come on to me where did you
get the money to do that because I know
when we met you didn't have any money
yes your flat broke at the time yes due
to a whole bunch of circumstances yeah
up to that so where did you get the
money to become compliant I was viewing
properties again as I do and I'd found
this really lovely one and I actually
met an investor at the DSM which is the
deal study mustika yes yes hold on a
minute
you became compliant you've also
invested in more training yes I'm just
really curious to find out where all
this money came from but we'll get that
so
okay so you want me to go back to nah
keep going till you make a deal selling
mustika yes I did and we part of the
course I think we had to get into pairs
and rig of estate agents and the person
I was sitting next to you pet it was
someone else and lots of other people
and I sort of sat there and I thought
there isn't anyone and I noticed someone
near the front sort of looking around
and we sort of did the nods do on it and
I thought yeah that's right yeah and
that's how I met him and what happened
so yeah we got paired up obviously what
we were doing things and I noticed like
a few things that he didn't quite seem
to understand and I was sort of pointed
out well actually you need to do this
and that and I think he should have come
to me and said oh I've got this great
one it's this and and when I worked at
the RO I said actually it's about nine
and he was like oh my goodness yeah so I
think just that sort of point
he's just thought she seems to know what
she's doing here so yeah we got we sort
of got chatting and then we both took
our seats and that was the end of that I
think it was at the end of that day he
came up to me and said oh you know we
need to swap numbers you know cuz I'm
only about an hour away from you you
know he's keeping context yeah that's
fine so yeah so I think it's a couple of
days after the course had finished he'd
contacted me and said um I'm looking for
some properties there's anything you can
help me with and I said well yes there
is actually there is one that I viewed I
think it might be perfect for what
you've described okay
he was about an hour away from me so
we're having these conversations but I
was finding it a little bit difficult so
I just said to him not tell you what how
about because again he was
extraordinarily busy and I said how
about I come to you on I think it was on
a Saturday yeah and he said yeah okay
that's fine so I thought you know let's
just stop talking and just you know
you're gonna do this or not
so yeah so I drove over to him and had a
good chat with him showed him everything
and he was really really pleased then I
explained to him I said I have to be
honest with you I said I'm not compliant
I said I either need to is it code eel
sauce with you know with somebody else
yeah I said or I I don't know really
what to do I suppose I'll just have to
give it to you I don't I don't know so
basically at this point you'd found an
investor
yes you'd fat you'd found a deal yes but
you weren't compliant so tecnique
in order to sell that bill to him you
believed in him and protected yourself
and protects exactly you're a very
ethical person and you thought I needed
I need to tell him what the situation is
so you told him and what did he say he
said to me he said some support is Kody
Lawson and I said well obviously you
know I'd have to split the fee you know
with somebody else and he said yes but
you're the one who's you know you're the
one with the investor you're the one
with the property now that seems a shame
and I said well that's the only legal
way to do it and he said well woman if
you get compliant and I said well
obviously I can do it but I don't have
the money and he said well I tell you
what I'll give you a thousand pounds now
to be compliant he said go and get
compliant he said and then come back on
Monday
what's your compliant and then we could
put in an offer for the property and
that's what I did that's brilliant
and then what happened put in an offer
it was a little bit back and forth which
again I was pleased my first offer was
rejected because it means that I think
if it was accepted I'd think oh I've
obviously done it too high so always
pleased it allowed you time for the for
the compliance thing to go well so I did
that obviously on the Saturday and
Sunday yeah got all the compliance
sorted
yeah putting the offer on Monday and I
think it was about five o'clock I think
it was on the Monday and it came through
that the offer was accepted so yeah I
contacted him and he was really really
happy so you got he paid for you to
become compliant did he pay you anything
else he did he paid me another two
thousand pounds
fantastic yes he was a very very good
genuine reasonable investor yes and
what's going on with that is that all
going through smoothly yeah absolutely
where's that where is that property
that's in Wellingborough okay no
property and what is it that is it's a
single it but it needs a lot of work
dough into it so once he's refinanced
the ROI is I think it's ridiculous like
29% from front of signaller
because of the amount you can add to the
value of the property how much is he
buying it for he's buying it for one
three seventy five hundred and what's
the reverb the reverb I think is going
to be a roundabout I think about five to
ten okay
yeah well actually he does oh so he
knows he knows yeah he's got he's got
his builder friends that they've already
been around and quoted for it yeah I
think the property itself was the father
I think died and left it to his children
right so they just wanted it sold so
they're happy to sell it cheap it just
and just quick and it needs a bit of
work done to it yes you're he's the
investors going to do it up and once the
what's the what's the expected GTV the
new value on it worst-case scenario
hundred and eighty
that's brilliant yeah Wow well that
sounds like you're gonna have a very
happy investor please you found it
yes you packaged it all up you got
everything ready you did the research
and now he's paying you three grand it
makes sense yes if I was him I'd pay for
you to become compliant yes so what he
said is he said that he wants to keep
doing it so he wants to stick with me so
if I'm compliant then we can just keep
doing it yeah exactly where did you
learn the skills to get so good at
property well how did this oh yes I went
to the crash course this I think was
September of last year and it really did
start for the crash course it really
really did I thought you know you people
say anything yeah go go and then you'll
understand you know so I walked out I
thought right that's it you know this is
this is where it really starts me and
there was obviously you discuss through
all the different the different types
you know that there is and I was
thinking do I do dill sauce in do I do
you know it went rare which you know
which one I'm interested in mmm and yeah
so it was just a case of sort of
learning them all and then I sort of
decided that deal was awesome and was
definitely the one that I wanted to do
so I booked on was if I can't think
heard ain't no early February wasn't it
yeah the deal selling masterclass yes
squeeze for you to do that and you have
to save up you have to use some of your
money that you made Dale sauce yeah but
you were so adamant that you knew that
the training yes for you it was just
like you know what you I've got money
and all that from the deal sauce which
is gray and I could use that to pay for
bells and but no I'm gonna actually put
myself first
yes yeah so when we went to Burnley on
the 30 years I think it was yeah you
obviously transferred the the two
thousand pounds into a monkey that day
yeah and I I think I was talking to
Amelia and I said to her when's your
next course and I think she said it was
about five or six days away and I said
can I go on it please I want to use that
money absolutely because you know I've
done this but there's still a lot of
holes in the sense that you know
everything that you sent over to the
investor I was thinking I wonder what
that is and what are your terms and
conditions what's this so you've got the
skills from the crash course of how to
find deals but then we and then when you
did the day with me yes I sold the
investor tomorrow I saw the deal to my
own investors and you thinking wow how
do I get a list of investors so then you
put the the money that you made towards
doing training times you then met
someone actually at the cause yes and
that's things you think other people say
as well can't you just find the
information online no I mean what's your
what's your thoughts on that the reason
why you can't find it online is because
you don't know what you're looking for
yeah that's the thing I learned things
on that course that I did not know
existed I did there's no way I could
have researched it when I don't know
what I'm looking for yeah it's just yeah
you don't know what you didn't know
until you know it it's as simple as that
so no I don't see how you can possibly
do it online unless you know what you're
looking for be and even if you do
there's so much nonsense online about
like with wrong information
I find that scary even on like Facebook
groups and stuff people ask questions
and the answers will be wrong
yes and I'm thinking that's the wrong
answer so there's night and I'm sort of
stuff that you read about deal sourcing
and it's wrong even from sometimes
so-called experts they say stuff that
it's just incorrect yes because you can
publish anything online yeah you know
and go into the program you know more
than anything it's not it's not a
seminar
doing ah yes it is you're actually doing
you're doing it and you saw on that on
that program you saw deals being sold
yeah investors being called you found an
investor yeah again you can do online
but you're on your own
yeah but money comes from people so
being around other investors which is
what you experienced yeah so how did you
find the deal saying masterclass I loved
it it was really really a good
investment
oh yeah hundred percent yeah it's just
you know when I obviously when I first
went on it I I do talk to people but I'm
not someone you know I'm not the person
walks into the room and say hey everyone
I'm here I'm not that type of person so
I was talking to a few people but I
think it was was it the second the
second day you pulled me up on stage and
then as soon as I sat down yeah like the
next break I was just like so many
people I'll watch your phone number and
you know and just yeah that's right
rested and yeah put yourself out there
like that
yes that's fantastic and I think as well
I mean what's great is you made your
money back from the training while you
were there by meeting an investor yes
which is just great it is yeah cuz I
think it was Alastair that actually said
you know there's and to be honest right
though cuz all the time people make
money on the program and of course you
see Alastair and myself for selling
deals you know on stage to investors so
that's exciting
okay so when you first heard me on the
phone even when we met for that day I
also an investor what did you learn from
that phone call because it was quite
different from what you'd previously
been doing and previously had seen
remember when I made when I sold the
deals the investor yes what what
happened what what was different was the
fact that he didn't ask you know can I
flee address you know all that that's
the sort of thing that you know you can
get sometimes but I think the thing is
when you've got the reputation when
you've you've got everything set out
they understand the process and they
will you know they will go with the
process so it's not just like although
they are strangers they feel that
they're not they feel I suppose like the
only one if that makes sense because
they don't know obviously how many other
people you've got in the books they
don't know how many you do when when
they ring up or when you know you're
doing a deal with them they they're the
only one you know in their heads you
know yeah so yeah it's just know just
what you learned from what happened on
the on the phone when I made when I when
I solved the deal you know the sale yeah
yeah yeah he said normally your
experience what you teen or heard or
tried was there's loads of questions yes
they do what's the door number and it
will have bigs the garden and yeah but I
what I learned from that and what what
is me and it makes me feel better
because I can actually be myself because
obviously I've seen you do it yeah is
just just you know just the fact that
you know it is what it is and then you
know they they just trust you or they
don't if they don't trust you then you
know or if they've they don't want not
you but if you they don't trust people
in general if then that type of person
then it's probably best if they don't
you know sort of go for it because there
are a lot of people that just say yeah
fine okay you've got you know you know
what you doing this looks fine that's
fine because they've got 14 days to view
it themselves and do their own throat do
they don't like it then the components
like exactly yeah it's like you know
let's just do this you've got 14 days to
sort it out if there's a problem if I've
missed something it's fine you know it's
absolutely fine they don't trust that
and they don't believe you and then
you've got a contract and if they don't
trust a contractor that I believe it
then as you say maybe it's best that
they find somebody that they do trust ya
because ultimately you can't get there
than that if you say look these are the
details these are the figures you know
you're gonna have a 14 day calling
period where you can do all your own
research there for any reason anything
I've said you're not happy with it you
can get a refund
yes so if they're serious and they
actually want our interest in the
property and actually want to buy
something you can't get there
exactly I think as well something that I
do is I'll ask them up for given the
details that of course see the email and
I'll say what else do you need to know
from me in order to make a decision and
then they'll don't ask me a question and
then rather than just answering it
immediately okay
it's or anything else is there anything
I get all their questions from them
upfront and then I say also bang bang
bang bang bang bang bang answer their
questions and then suddenly it's like
they've just said that that's that's all
they need to know in order to make a
decision
so you answer all their questions and
then it's just a case of do too close
and I think it is a sales call yes but
people think that sales is trying to be
pushy or trying to be but the thing is
before they even ask questions any
question at all you're gonna do what ask
them questions yes so what kind of
questions do you ask you investors now
are they cash are they mortgage yeah
what sort of property they're looking
for do they want to be hands-on or
hands-off mm-hmm you know sort of how
quick are they thinking about doing this
there might be just sort of thinking
about it at this stage or they might be
say yes we are ready to go yeah and then
sort of yeah how much they've got or
whatever and then that sort of depends
on what sort of area mm-hmm
because often the people that will ask
you the most questions and pick your
brain about everything to do the
property to door number this and that
there are people that aren't gonna buy
anyway they haven't got any money
they're just probably wanting to be deal
sources themselves trying to steal your
deals or just trying to understand the
process of how it works so when someone
calls at me and says hey I'm interested
in the deal I'll say no problem well
look before before before we go into it
is it all I've asked you a few questions
yeah sure oh I'm great and then I go and
ask those questions yeah and then
suddenly you're the person in control
you're pre-qualifying then it's they're
serious and they've got the money in
there ready to go then great then then
then you can go into the going to talk
to both about the deal with them if
they're not oh well so if you say to
someone if I was just presented deal to
you it was right would you be in a
position where you could move today not
really because I need to speak to my
lawyer and my dog and all right cool
listen this deals gonna go today I've
got a lot of investors that have emailed
me and text me you saw how many people
mess
42 it was a ridiculous in the space of
less than an hour yes duty was it I want
it I want it I want it I want it I want
it I want it so I can genuine hand on
heart say yeah you know look there's a
lot of other people that are interested
so this is gonna go today
yeah so if you're not quite ready yet my
suggestion is maybe give me a call back
when you see another day and you are
ready because this one needs to go today
yes if they're serious and they're like
yeah I'm really if the deals right then
I'm good great what kind of deal you're
looking for exactly yes awesome
questions up front get their information
great well let me tell you about the
deal boom boom boom boom boom
how does that sound it sounds really
good great I'm gonna get the terms of
conditions everything sent over are you
in a position where you be able to pay
that today it's just closing the deal
yes you know and I think that's what
people suck us so bad yeah and the thing
is I think they sort of need to
understand is is you know I intend to do
this a lot
yeah so I'm not gonna rip you off
because I want a good reputation of
course you know I want to continue to do
this every business you need to be able
to market yourself yes right now you're
marketing yourself ah being on this
podcast yes I'll put a link in the
description with your website thank you
so you're generating eyeballs cuz if no
one knows who you are they can't buy
from you exactly market next sales
that's what we talk about right now
gotta be able to sell next delivery
yes you want to always over deliver and
then there's the finance side of things
okay in the business so when people
sometimes people said to me no I'm not
sales person Oh Samuel will just try and
sell to you what do you better believe
it because if I didn't sell then I
wouldn't have money because sales equals
money yes but the good news is I over
deliver so you're alright yes because
then you then you ruin your reputation
and then you can't sell anymore so you
know and I think people people don't get
this you can be the but you were
brilliant and finding deals after the
crash course you couldn't sell a deal
yes because you didn't have a market you
didn't own a cell yep now you know how
to sell now you're learning a bit about
the marketing side yes which is which is
happening and
and you're making money now which is
awesome what would your advice be to
your six month younger self at the crash
course leaving the crafts course fired
up
what would your advice be I think it
would just be you know just carry on
what you do Indy it's gonna work out all
right yeah you know but it is hard work
what was the hardest point depends what
you mean by hard when was the fli given
up no really no hmm so nothing's been
that hard you were struggling a bear
when you message i'ma be messaging me
about my cue three months ago before we
spend the day together and you were
viewing houses but you had no money yeah
you had no investors yeah so you're
viewing lots of houses and a lot of
people telling you a stupid they were
discouraging you you were having to pay
for petrol yeah a few houses and you
didn't have a lot of money so it was it
was hitting your finances sure you felt
like even up now no I thought no what
kept me going the fact that I enjoyed
doing it yeah and I was learning every
single time good sometimes we're the
state agents you know if they're trying
to sell a property sometimes they might
possibly want people to view it so it
looks like they're doing their work so
they don't mind be viewing it even if
they don't know don't think I'm gonna
buy it it's not like wasting their time
or anything like that you know so you
know and it's just a case of the people
that were sort of saying to me you know
at the time what if you you know you're
gonna buy all these I'm not no I'm not
gonna buy more why are you doing so many
then they're the people of now that are
coming to me saying how much is that
house worth and aren't you that because
I know now yeah
I've been studying it for such a long
time I know how much they're worth
almost without looking at the price yes
brilliant did did you have a lot of
people try and hold you back not hold me
back but they just didn't understand
yeah to be honest they didn't understand
it so what was their motivation like for
pooping on your parade was it just was
there trying to protect you were they
just confused with a threatened by you
what do you think the the spirit behind
people because you had a lot of people
such saying you know you something
like what was what their motivation was
I think it's I think it's kind of you
know the time that you're viewing these
properties you could hadn't done another
two hours at work yeah you could have
done actually two hours overtime and got
paid what 16 pounds or whatever it is it
you know I'm like yeah I know I could
have done that you know I've been to
work all day or whatever I want to go
and view some houses because I want to
be in that side of it I don't want to
walk over than 16 pounds that's that's
not yeah that's not what I want yeah I
think it was it was a bit like that I
think it was a bit like sort of you know
that that's you know people that buy
houses and do things that's for them not
for you yeah but not in a horrible way
but yeah you know I almost try and just
protect you then maybe I don't want to
see you waste time they don't want to
see you buy into a pipe dream I mean
that's the me I get accused of people
say that I sell people dreams are you
just selling you just selling dreams too
vulnerable poor people it's like no no
no the people that I'm training the
people just like I used to be because
when I started I had no money I'm from a
working-class background I'm not like a
guy who was born into wealth and Scott
you know so all I had to really work for
it and I learned a lot along the way and
I'm just sharing my skills with people
you can I'm saying yeah no nothing it's
a noble thing but the same people that
didn't understand you what are you doing
that doesn't make sense
people don't understand me and I think
sometimes you're never gonna win people
over because a lot of people I know
you've got some really nice friends as
well as some beautiful people around you
but I think you might have heard me say
before firstly you have the you know
what are you doing stage I don't do that
then you have the well we'll see what
happens
yes you know let's just it and you're
kind of probably at that stage right now
let's see what happens all right you
made five gun the last five weeks but
let's just see what happens actually
yeah I haven't told my friends if I've
told them no because I've Oh like I've
almost kind of lost them all of them
believe it or not yeah believe it or not
because my path seems to be going in a
different direction to those I'm now at
the stage where you know sort of you
know do you want to come out to the Pope
you want to do this I'm
no because I want to go and read a book
I'm at that stage now where I'm drifting
apart from them you know you know it's
difficult but I'm finding that I can't
talk to them because my knowledge now is
quite advanced compared to theirs and
they don't understand and we can't have
that conversation so the people that I
spend most of my time with now are
people that have been on the courses
that I can talk to about things and it's
a shame because I've got I've got two
Facebook pages right one of like sort of
my old life so to speak and one of my
new life and when I first started when I
first did it I spent most of our time on
the other one but my original one now I
probably go on it about once a week just
to see you know what sort of going on
because I've got so many friends now
within my I know it's I still got one
life but I like I always think of it was
two lives yeah my new life and I put the
video on I think it was on my original
Facebook and a lot of people watched it
but nobody commented I didn't have
anybody saying oh well done or nothing
they just nothing nothing and I don't
and I don't understand what that means
so that's weird I can't tell him because
I think there'll be a lot of people that
will either say oh you know like 3,000
pounds to some of my friends it might as
well be a million you know and it'll be
kind of like I think some of them might
be a bit oh well you you can do this you
can pay for this you can do this for me
now or it will be a bit sort of oh it's
alright for you now isn't it you've got
money and so I haven't told him that's
so strange and it's weird that people
haven't even commented a nine-year-old
but then on the obviously I'm not
friends of you on your own yeah but you
do want people comment so much yes
there's so much love and positivity on
that yeah
and I've had so many people messaged me
saying you know I don't comment on your
post or anything but I'm looking at them
all and I really enjoyed you know
watching you know misting or reading
them every day yeah
and these people are from I mean some of
them are from California some from
Australia but they're all in the
property business yeah and they're just
interested in you know and things like
that you've made a lot of friends on the
horses tell me about that
yeah I've just yeah yeah I met I met
someone on the on the crash course yeah
we have literally been chatting like
first of all it was like almost every
day after the course but we talked to
each other all the time all the time
since crash course on that know that's
somebody else Oh different that's
somebody else yeah I think he he lives
half an hour away from her so it's like
everyone I meet has to be up north but
yeah it's just such a lovely it's just
so lovely yeah I think it was when you
pulled me up on stage actually you know
I sat down a lady came up to you and she
said oh she said I didn't realise you
know and I said I was so nervous and she
said oh well if that's you nervous then
she said because I hadn't got a clue she
said you did really well and I said I
thank you very much she really meant it
and then she just walked off and I
thought how lovely yeah
this stranger can just say that yeah
it's so strange and I think that in the
in my world and I've said this to you
before everyone is so supportive and
positive everyone wants you to win yes
but in the out there yes in the I guess
you call it in the real world but for me
it's not the real world people don't
want other people to succeed yes and
when you start succeeding people try and
drag you down exactly and my advice
always is to just surround yourself with
people that want you to win yes there's
better friends exactly a life yeah I
mean an example of that was when I
caught the train this morning I was on
the platform and this man walked along
with a strange sort of shaped briefcase
but you could tell you've got money the
way you use dress everything else and he
sort of walked down the platform and
then the couple next to me we're going
look at him I think she knows it all and
stuff like that and I thought he's not
done anything he's just walked down the
platform with a briefcase and yet you're
all slugging him off you don't know who
he is or what do you know anything about
him but they just saw that as he's got
money said they just liked him off what
do you think people hate on people of
them because I think that they don't
realize that they could yeah
that's honestly what I think I think
they separate it and thinks all right
for them with the money it's like no it
could be you with the money they haven't
done anything different to what you've
done
yeah you know that you were both born
you both you both do what you want you
know you the books are out there the
courses around everything's out there
he's done it why don't you do it and
then you could be walking down there
with your briefcase yeah totally
what do you think you're gonna get up to
this year what are the plans how you
gonna get on Windows Wednesday cuz
you're close the other thing I've done
as well is I found a property that just
needs a lot of work doing and so it was
suggested to possibly do a joint venture
I send this to you eventually
so I put it on I can't remember what
Facebook page it was I put it on there
but I didn't ask for it I just sort of
roped something and then people would
sort of message to well why don't you do
a joint venture and I said that's a good
idea I didn't think about after and then
I had about sort of ten people messaged
me I was chatting to those and getting
things worked out and hopefully I think
by next month I will be getting the keys
- yeah - a party
so now their joint venture you'll be a
joint venture that's gonna be exciting
yes it's gonna be a flip okay and once
it goes on market hopefully we'll be
getting between 20 and 25 thousand pound
each oh wow that's incredible and as
well I mean I know you said on the
documentary your salary up until this
point wasn't particularly high yes it
was what like a grand a month
yeah so making 25 grand from one flip is
just insane it is insane that's
incredible that I think once you've done
that a joint venture and if you kept up
the deal sourcing for a few months I
think you're so gonna be
winners Wednesday were they um and also
as well I know Amelia thinks a lot of
you as well she heads up all the winners
but what's what's the what's the
relationship being like there
we've just that company as a whole of
working with us Oh fantastic absolutely
fantastic I think I spoke to you was it
only about a week or so ago I'm Finn
like wow yeah it's just yes it were just
checking up and Amelia's always
messaging me you know how you doing
you know something right anything you
need just let me know yeah all the time
that's so so okay final piece of advice
golden nugget to leave the listeners
with that want to start deal sourcing
okay yeah I've had a lot of people
message me this actually so yeah see it
with you yeah you've been messaged you
feel almost a committee celebrity over
the last month yeah I think the videos
had 15,000 views now you've been on
stage yes and you've been message most
of the response it must be positive all
positive is be more positive positive
good yeah all the messages are being
positive so the only people yeah it
really does so so when people message
then and they're asking you for advice
and things what's the biggest gold
another the main thing they say is how
inspiring the video is yeah how much
that they they've watched that and for
all yes you know and I think a lot of
people have said to me I'm gonna start
doing this tomorrow and I've really
booked for this and already gone on to
this in the garage and everything else
what I say to them is I say right what
have you done so far away you're out
anybody that says I haven't done
anything yet I say right crash course
yeah straightaway and once you've done
that then by all means come back to me
but up until that point I'm gonna hand
them over to you and you could do all
the hard work it's free many people
can't even travel to the crash course
they're never gonna make it
no it's not they just want you to just
give them a quick three-point guide over
a Facebook message it's gonna suddenly
solve all their problems and make them a
millionaire then they're in cloud
cuckoo-land yes you've got to do the
training because the thing is property
investing is the most lucrative
profession on the place
yeah for anything you wanted if you want
to be a hairdresser so if you want to be
a plumber if you want to be a doctor you
need training and people think that they
can just pick someone's brain over a
free coffee yes and then suddenly
they're gonna have to start doing it
let's get trained and that's what a
training company exactly I can't skip
that step so kruskal's all the way yes
and then what if it's dual source and
then go on the dsm yeah deal selling
master class yeah that's where we
specifically hone in on how to build you
investors how to sell deals how to
package them email them all that sort of
things yeah that's great exactly so yeah
I mean if any one sort of said Wow I
don't have the money for this but I was
money for that or whatever then co deal
source with somebody yeah you know or do
something because I'm the mother
yeah I entered the competition one it
went to Burnley and obviously you give
me two thousand pounds yeah that's how I
went on it so I didn't have the money
either yeah that was my way of doing it
but you though literally you know you
were spending money that you didn't
really have yep on training on hotel
bells and you sacrificed a lot to do
that so when people were saying because
I need to even get any negativity I saw
a couple of comments saying oh it's
alright for you kind of comment one or
two you know I only because samuel was
there it's like yeah but you made that
happen I did make it happen you made it
happen I didn't come to you randomly no
I didn't just say you know ah I'll just
I'll just spin and roll a Dyson I came
to you because you came to the crash
course put yourself out there you were
active on social media you're commenting
on everything your book the most
viewings out of anyone you were so
active I just thought how I can't not
yes so I came and then when I came you
like a sponge yes we should respect we
spent the whole as you get up until when
he went dark we were at negotiating
outside people's offices did you in fact
remember that point when I cuz because
we separated actually for a short while
and we were trying to find which I
couldn't get hold of the agent and we
really wanted to speak to the seller we
were calling a medium answer we
separated you were in a different car I
wasn't yeah and then I was driving and I
saw the seller Darrien there yes I was
calling you you weren't answering and
I heard let's call him over I didn't
want to negotiate because I wanted you
to do so I was like hold on just wait
just wait just wait and then I was
waiting for you I was calling you I'll
get irritated you would just got lost or
something
my nose is putting this sat-nav and went
to a previous property I was doing what
he's doing but his Co just got cold feet
is she gonna go because we're filming
all day they want it to go off yeah and
then obviously putting the postcode of
the world we suppose began I said how
fast it she's like 10 minutes oh you are
so I'm coming there with a sir how cold
it's windy
be here in a second to make you a very
cheeky officer so just stand there in
the cold and then you came it was like
to go shade out in the dark stuff yeah
for you you worked so hard so I think
honestly I think you deserve every
success that you've had up into this
point and I'm really really excited
about seeing what happens over the next
few months and getting you on Windows
Wednesday's soon so yeah thanks so much
for coming on the show thank you very
much guys if you enjoyed this and if you
want to get to know Chloe we're gonna
leave a link for clothes website I'm
also gonna leave a link for the property
investors crash course it's free it's
two days and I'm gonna leave a link
below so get yourself booked on thank
you so much for listening and see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]